hey what's up Thea what's up Chris ET
baby gorgeous hope you guys are doing
great I'm my name's Nick I am from
Aurora Illinois and my question for
Chris actually for both of you if you
both could answer this would be great
but for Chris I know that you had
started a career in physical therapy and
I was wondering what was the moment and
what made you decide to pursue stand-up
full-time and what like what was going
on I'm always curious to know like what
it was that made you transition into
different career paths like it was
stand-up maybe just a hobby was it
always a passion and how was that for
you how did that go and for you as well
Theo like what were you doing when you
decided that you were gonna do stand-up
and become a comedian full time and how
was that like for you as well it's
something I'm always interested in to
know with with anyone that pursue
something as crazy as stand-up so i
thanks guys thank you so much i
appreciate have a great rest of the day
Gang Gang Gang Gang thank you for very
articulate I did not expect him to be as
articulate and well-spoken and well
mannered and soft it's like in a
positive way yeah as he was I thought it
was gonna come out because last time I
did the podcast your fans were just
coming out swinging saying I want to
fight you [ __ ] you right now and see ya
because because they were only going off
what they had seen of me oh the enemy
was you and I and hoping each other
rhythm Opie but now again positive
because I came on your show and some of
your fans start listening to my stuff I
could see they're using calling me baby
gorgeous and Chrissie chlamydia they
listened so it's a different thing I
appreciate all this yeah look man up
Rishi I'm glad that you're here dude the
good the good thing all right I held a
guy's hands like this hold on bro
fingers bro huh
you got those [ __ ] perfect ass
fingers it's not perfect you that I very
very like kind of the hands of the you
could barely [ __ ] choke somebody does
have somebody else just come and help
you nah dude they're [ __ ] good in
there salt and you don't bite your nails
either um I do my but my thumbs are good
you got sexy ass cuticles really I think
so look at this finger cutting all about
that fingers disgusting that looks like
a et yeah yeah that's gross yeah you
actually fingers are a little long
yeah fingers though they shouldn't be
real not long you could just rock your
toes man
with no I'm does my feet are discussing
they grow over each other I could easily
see that it's disgusting yeah you wanna
you look like somebody would have webbed
feet on this I don't have webbed feet
but I believe I was born with broken
feet and they never fixed it yes I just
thought my feet are broken take care of
yourself okay that's what I'm saying
you look how you got it definitely was
in the band and the school band even
though it wasn't really in it here are
like the marching thing with the flag
yeah dude you look like my my third
grade gym teacher mrs. Klein yeah she
was like this lesbo we used to call Liu
Kang you kind of look like a little can
use my vitamin if he was a white dude in
that money that's awesome what but
honest what you guys didn't answer his
question oh go ahead you want to start
yeah so uh yeah what was I doing I mean
I was always doing something else on the
side until comedy was just enough of a
job you know I think at a certain point
it just kind of chooses you I always I
think even till about like ten years in
I was like am I gonna keep doing this am
I gonna keep doing this at some point I
have to grow up it feels like comedy for
me I always felt like a place rocket I
could just be I never had to grow up you
get to travel all the time you get to
escape whatever was going on in your
regular life he had you always got to
get out of town if you were from
thoughts being a relationship I gotta go
I gotta get it you know there was always
you're always on the go you're never to
be in one space you never had to really
kind of deal with you're with yourself I
guess and right of it so comedy always
gave me that the ability to escape I
felt like and then at a certain point I
was like oh I'm getting older I need to
figure out am I gonna have you know what
am I gonna do here how am I gonna have a
real future and then yeah I think at
some point he just kind of chose me it
was like okay there's enough here where
I can survive you know so I'm gonna stay
what I always liked about you as you are
a guy that you had to really not that it
mattered but there was a lot of proving
that you have to do to your peers
because when you started out it was real
world and then you start doing stand-up
and already people like nah he's a real
world guy he's not a real stand-up and
then your career like you said was like
just maintaining maintaining maintaining
did the Netflix special and it's just
maintaining and then you start to prove
yourself in the podcast game and then
they say Oh
well he's just starting to podcast you
know he's still the real world guy but
then you start to explode with the
podcast and then it got to the point was
like now I've said that real world thing
I don't think anybody I know for a fact
no one even thinks about that with the
only way they're like that was something
he did 15 years ago now it's just like
grey podcaster great stand-up it's matte
so I don't sometimes as a peer of yours
in the comedy world
we I notice I'm like that was pretty
insane I was able to do all that the
random fan may not know that things like
oh I've always [ __ ] with do but it's
like way you had to come from because
you could have easily quit it's my point
was are you saying ten years it's like
I'm sure you heard it cuz if I heard it
in New York then you heard it was like
oh is the real world dude but you know
we don't want to be known as that like
just now am I starting [ __ ] oh you that
guy from guy code where it's like that's
a part of me that I'm proud of it but
now it's like they know my name a little
bit they know my podcast they know me
for stand-up not for being a talking
head and you are not known for being on
a reality show yeah you know so it takes
a lot of work to do that so I'm I'm
always noticing about you and that's I
started stint just to answer the family
question yeah I was a pediatric physical
therapist of a doctor degree in physical
therapy it's crazy dude it really is
crazy man when you get skull-fuck you
pass change you know so I went and I
became a physical therapist I was
working with children pediatric mentally
and physically handicapped children was
a beautiful job
but then simultaneously I got on guy
code and guy code really started to pop
off on mtv2 and then they created girl
code and that really started to pop off
so what happened was see the thing is
this is you know there's a lot of a lot
of the people who are watching the shows
were younger people 18 19 20 21 22 is a
college younger people show on MTV and
MTV to and it's very well-known that
older women sometimes will give birth to
a child with a disability you know
there's a lot of testing up women as
they get older have to do it's less and
less now but it's still a thing that's
where people are so my biological clock
but what's also not as known but is very
true is younger women 17:16 pre they
don't have the proper prenatal care and
they don't know that they're pregnant so
their children are born with high
disability rates as well definitely in
high sugar today always at Sonic I
always at Sonic yeah oh so so they so
they a lot of the moms and dads if the
children I was treating were young
people that were watching God code and
girl code and the principal of the
school I was working I was like look we
found out you're doing comedy of doing
these TV shows and they're like it's not
you can't be treating handicapped
children and also doing a show about the
guy code to hiding your boner so you're
gonna have to choose mmm and so it was
really this little kid my little man
Aaron great kid he was in a wheelchair
had cerebral palsy so cognitively he was
fine no problems with speech or his mind
worked like our minds but his legs
didn't work from cerebral palsy so he
was sitting in his wheelchair one day we
were throwing the ball at him you know
he would throw it at me I would you know
rifle it off his legs he couldn't feel
it anyway so I was just rifle it up you
know light him with you know burn him
with cigarettes
he couldn't feel [ __ ] I would tell him
to close his eyes just yeah like his
pants on fire joke around have a pet bat
bite him yeah yeah I'm kidding obviously
I'm Ken he's your agent now he's my
agent no so Aaron so um so Aaron told me
I was when I was four with this idea of
leaving a physical therapy he's six
years old but the thing is when you're
six year old kid that's got a disability
you're you're so wise beyond your years
yeah so the reason because the you know
man asked me what why what made me
change
I was always flirting with the idea of
leaving for a year I was like I should
Lee I need to jump 2 feet in if I really
want to do stand-up and then it got to
the point where Aaron told me we were
talking throwing the ball back and forth
and and I was like I kind of want to
leave stand-up I kind of want to leave
physical therapy to do stand-up but I'll
miss you guys so much so I don't know if
I could do it and he was like well it
isn't stand-up isn't being a comedian
your dream and I said yeah it is and he
goes so why wouldn't you go why wouldn't
you go do it if that's what you always
want to do and I was like I was like I
don't know I'm gonna miss you guys and
he was like he was and he said to me he
was like I'm not going anywhere I can't
walk I'm always gonna be sitting in this
chair waiting for you he's like but I
want to Aaron said this to me he goes I
wanted I think it's pretty cool if I
could see one of my therapy my teachers
he called he calls teacher one of my
teachers on TV he said I would think
that was pretty cool he said and if I
had that opportunity I would go on
I would hope you would want to watch me
and be proud of me and he said we're all
proud of you I think you should go do it
and go live your dream and that was like
damn and then cuz I would say it cuz cuz
he said cuz I and then I said to him I
said the most like how are you so smart
how are you so smart like this and how
are you so brave and then he said like
I'll never forget he was like well he
was like you see mr. Chris it was like a
[ __ ] movie he's like you see mr.
Chris he said when you can't walk or use
your legs and you're in a wheelchair he
said you have all day to sit and think I
said so I'm thinking about you and I
think you should go do it and then I
swear to God I [ __ ] relieve myself
hysterical crying like three hours later
I told the principal I was like I'm
gonna leave he's just patch Adams I
think yeah it was fun Wow then I tried
put Chinese finger traps and [ __ ] on his
toes I took those off I swear he
remarkable yeah how much time you have
to think there's how still probably your
world gets mean you can't even because
it was that that pushed me and also I
this is true too I had sex with four of
the teachers at different times and the
heat was starting to get turned up they
all found out about it so they were
starting to get a little heated in that
physical therapy three days for that
drip drop so between Aaron telling me to
go live my dream and and these girls you
know about to press charges it was it
was time to leave good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one